men don't have affairs by large for sex
if they wanted sex they would go
primarily to prostitutes or if they
really want sex
stay at home and have sex with your wife
men have affairs for affirmation it's
something that I captured in a book I
wrote called the book in American mail
and then the book and American male
thesis is very simple our culture is
structured like a pyramid we men only
get to read about the people at the top
third of the pyramid or even in the
pinnacle of the pyramid we read everyday
about Bill Gates we read everyday about
LeBron James and with this constant
emphasis on financial success
professional success a lot of us are
made to feel like we're failures and in
that feeling of failure we turn to women
other than our wives in order to feel
like winners the the great cathedrals of
Europe these enormous giant cathedrals
there's two ways to build them one is
with the giant support structures in the
middle and you see that often the other
was with something called a flying
buttress it's where you want to keep the
space hollow and fit in as many people
as possible so you support the structure
with these buttresses that are that hold
the structure up from the outside well a
man can either have his wife who's his
support network who is one of the great
pillars of his sense of self is
self-esteem and she helps him to hold up
the entire structure of who he is and
that's healthy a soul mate or you can
have the flying buttress it's where
you're Hollow and empty on the inside
you feel like you don't have any real
self-worth you feel insignificant you
feel anonymous you feel that some of
your life's achievements does not amount
to much so you get someone from the
outside to help raise the structure
that's the principal reason why men have
affairs and you will ask yourself well
if I need a woman to tell me how
valuable I am in order to feel good
about myself why can't it be my wife and
the answer for the broken American male
is simple if I think of myself as a
giant zero then the woman dumb enough to
marry me is a zero squared
she's an even bigger loser than I am
it's specifically this
Ranger who did not marry me it is
specifically the person who is not
related to me who still has value
everyone remembers when AOL was just a
dial-up internet company and it took
over Time Warner that owned one of our
the studios HBO CNN well AOL lost its
value and it pulled Time Warner after
the acquisition all the way down it was
only when they separated the two
companies at Time Warner stock went back
up a lot of husbands do that to their
wives they take beautiful women smart
accomplished professional women loving
women and as soon as they married them
with their broken sense of self they
transfer the sense of nothingness onto
their wives
thereby necessitating necessitating the
affair the woman who is not your wife to
make you feel good about yourself now
you begin to see why it specifically
sometimes the biggest achievers who end
up being so susceptible to
unfaithfulness to adultery what is the
story of Tiger Woods it's a story of a
boy who was told by a loving father
you'll probably meant it for its best
but he was told from the time he's a
child look you're okay you're a cute kid
but if you learn to use this metal stick
better than anyone who's used it before
you're gonna be somebody well the
message you get is that now you're
nobody
and no matter and you can have all these
metals that surround you and you can
have all these trophies but you still
don't internalize that sense of
achievement
so you marry your wife and she doesn't
make you feel good about yourself so you
may be subconsciously blame her it's
other women who tell you you're amazing
notice that Tiger Woods did not cheat
for variety you know the argument is
that men are basically evolutionary
inseminate errs who seek the widest
possible possible distribution of their
gene pool and hence it's no mystery that
they cheat they look for a variety
variety all the women the Tiger Woods
cheated with were carbon copies of his
wife where was the Asian woman
where was the voluptuous curvaceous
woman where was the African American
woman he was cheating with blonde
blue-eyed Nordic bombshells that really
looked almost identical to his wife
because he was cheating for a totally
different
purpose it was to feel accomplished Bill
Clinton was president United States and
yet interestingly most powerful mountain
world he fell susceptible to the charms
of a woman who stood on line 10 hours
just to see him which was really
flattering
was incredibly flattering because even
the most powerful man in the world may
not see himself as such remember Bill
Clinton story is a painful one and he
comes from a very broken even tragic
beginning with his father dying when he
was just a baby and then his his
stepfather and he had to take his
stepfather off of his mother from
beating her with like a lead pipe and
this man has seen really horrible things
and sometimes it's hard to put those
pieces back together that's why we men
have to heal ourselves if we don't heal
ourselves then I fear that we will
spread some of that toxicity and that
dysfunction to our families and of
course it applies to women as well let's
not forget at the rates of female
infidelity or skyrocketing having said
that there still seems to be a principle
difference in why a man cheats and why
woman cheats a man cheats for the ego
boost and for affirmation women almost
always cheat out of neglect
you know the studies really show that
wives whose sexual emotional and
romantic needs are addressed in marriage
don't really cheat they're actually
pretty happy with their husbands it
doesn't mean that they have a monogamous
nature the recent evidence is showing
that women do not have a monogamous
nature that's okay but they do have a
nature that responds to the affection
and focus of a man whereas men you know
sometimes the most loving wife the most
devoted wife and sometimes men are still
cheating when a married couple are
sitting on my couch and it's a painful
and tragic thing to witness after she
discovered that husbands been unfaithful
and there are very few things that are
is painful to feel that you're discarded
it's amazing that the husband's to
comfort their wives will say to me on
that couch will say to their wives on
that couch but I didn't love her I love
you so what are they really saying I
didn't
her eye lusted after her I loved you but
I lusted after her now if you ever put
love and lust in a boxing ring together
lust is going to crush love and that's
what they're really saying so why don't
we emphasize lust in marriage more if
love can't compete with lust why we
demonized lust why have we made lust
something that should be found only in
porn or it's something that only singles
get to experience but married couples
settle down they get to love each other
any marriage that doesn't have intense
strong desire any marriage that doesn't
have lust is becoming something of a
prison it's where you're kind of there
for reasons other than wanting each
other maybe because it's comfortable
maybe because you appreciate and cherish
each other maybe because of the kids
maybe because you've nowhere else to go
and maybe because you even feel that you
belong there that's okay but it's still
a form of external incarceration you're
not there out of a deep desire to be
there lust is where you want that person
and that's why you're there and that has
to be the primary reason that we go into
marriage and that we stay in marriage
and I maintain passionately
that the passion need not be lost that
this idea that there's a transition in
marriage from lust to love that when
you're single you can't keep your hands
off of each other but it slowly migrates
into this partnership such a cold
commercial expression that it slowly
migrates into this partnership I that's
balderdash it's a it's a defeatist
approach to marriage it's one that I
cannot embrace and it's one that I have
to argue against and the reason I wrote
coach your lust
you